faciliter les perquisitions
administrative voici la première
disposition du projet de loi soumis au
conseil des ministres
cette mesure n'est pas tout neuf la loi
de 2010 est permettait déjà de pénétrer
chez un individu soupçonné de menaces
terroristes
à condition que la menace soit d'une
particulière gravité
le nouveau projet de loi conserve cette
notion le gouvernement souhaitait
pourtant nuancer la formule pour
faciliter le recours à cette mesure
mais l'exécutif a choisi d'y renoncer
après avis du conseil d'état
le nouveau projet de loi propose aussi
de porter de 1 à 2 ans les mesures de
surveillance pour les personnes
condamnées pour terrorisme et libéré
sur les 500 personnes condamnées en
france une centaine a été libéré en 2020
soixante autres en 2021 en août 2001 le
conseil constitutionnel avait censuré
une proposition similaire de la
république en marche
à la fermeture des lieux de culte
accusée d'être liée à des faits de
nature terroriste
le projet de loi ajoute la possibilité
de fermer des locaux indépendants géré
par les associations liées à ces lieux
de culte le but éviter que ces
fermetures d'établissements soit
contournée une personne sous
surveillance administrative est tenue de
résider dans un périmètre déterminé aura
interdiction de se rendre dans un lieu
où se tient un événement soumis à un
risque terroriste particulier le texte
propose également de pérenniser le
recours aux algorithmes controversé
cette technique s'appuie sur le
traitement automatisé des données de
connexion sur internet et permettrait la
détection d'individus
isolé enfin le texte élargit la
possibilité d'obtenir le concours des
opérateurs de télécommunications il
porte à deux mois la durée de
l'autorisation de recueil des données
informatiques
la conservation des renseignements à des
fins de recherche seraient permises et
l'interception des correspondances
échangées par voie satellitaire facilité